[Musique]
c'était déjà vu la première partie de la
faq vous avez été tellement nombreux à
me poser des questions qu'il a fallu non
seulement faire le tri et encore désolé
mais en plus faire une deuxième partie
on a assez perdu de temps comme ça on
chez nous avec la suite
[Musique]
j'ai toujours infirmiers ou tu
travailles que sur youtube j'exerce ce
plu comme infirmier mon métier
maintenant c'est youtuber et auteur et
comédien est ce que tu t'en sors avec
tes vidéos est ce que tu vas ouvrir un
tipi je ne vis pas de mes vidéos même
loin de là mais j'espère que ça va venir
donc non j'ai envie d'acheter un nouvel
article le jour où un labo te demandera
de faire du placement de produits est ce
que tu nous préviendra bulbes d'été
cessé mon activité principale est que
pour l'instant ça paye pas mon loyer les
partenariats ça peut être une solution
mais je serai évidemment super vigilant
sur trois points que le partenariat soit
clairement indiquée
bien sûr que le partenaire soit fiable
et sérieux et que je garde la liberté
totale dans tout ce que je raconte
si tu dois arrêter youtube pour x ou y
raison dans quoi aimerais tu travailles
et si je dois arrêter youtube j'aimerais
bien continuer en tant qu'auteur et
entendre comédiens voir chroniqueur pas
forcément dans la santé d'ailleurs
peut-on vraiment agrandir des membres de
son corps
je pense notamment aux doigts pour les
musiciens
je pense que tu manges c'est pas ça qui
pensent qu'elle a été la pire expérience
médicale beaucoup de choses qui sont
difficiles à vivre quand on côtoie la
maladie la mort le désarroi des familles
au quotidien
vraiment mais je crois que ce qui m'a le
plus marqué c'est les morts subites du
nouveau né quand je travaillais au
suivant je sais pas si vous imaginez une
famille qui nage dans le bonheur absolu
et en une minute tout bascule dans
l'horreur la violence à l'état brut
quelle est la vidéo que tu as préféré
tourner pour ta chaîne et ou pour des
potes sur youtube sur dtc j'aime
beaucoup les vidéos avec des invités et
celle où je vais tester des trucs sur le
terrain mais ma préférée ça reste celle
sur l'anus artificiel parce que c'était
la toute première avec les potes bomba
pour l'instant j'ai surtout des petits
rôles mais j'ai vraiment adoré celui
d'anthony shon squared au raf des cracks
vraiment
et on a aussi beaucoup rigolé sur le
tournage de l as pété de mr bean sur le
plateau deux en fait
et parlons peu parlons q c'était aussi
très très chouette je peux vous le dire
et puis on a aussi un autre mais je peux
pas vous en parler pour l'instant ça
viendra sauver passion et sinon à quand
le livre de vulgarisation a peut-être
bientôt on sépare prévoit tu de
participer à des conventions comme tu
l'as fait au japan tour festival et ce
serait le feu si romain pouvait venir
aussi
moi quand on m'invite je viens à chaque
fois c'est des moments super cool à
chaque fois j'invite romain et à chaque
fois il peut pas parce que il a mieux à
faire
donc oui j'en referai d'ailleurs je
serai au french festival d'avignon les 2
et 3 septembre prochain avec un paquet
de gens je ne lui dis que ça pour la faq
j'aimerais que tu nous montres où tu
travailles l'envers du décor
bah je travaille ici donc l'envers du
décor c'est ça envoie depuis petit
peloton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà qu'elle est hors ue beurre préféré
alors déjà il faut savoir qu'à chaque
fois qu'on me demande mon ou ma préférée
dans le n'importe quel domaine je perd
environ 13 minutes d'espérance de vie
parce que je déteste choisir mais bon
disons je regarde essentiellement des
contenus humour et les gens qui me font
le plus rire c'est mon frère bien sûr
nattes ou flaubert que marc et plein
d'autres je suis pas dire thème toujours
les saucisses ça si tu vois la dtcc fini
pour aujourd'hui merci pour toutes vos
questions pour tous vos messages merci
d'être là tout simplement
on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle vidéo d'ici là vous savez ce
que vous avez à faire
mettez vous bien et surtout
reportez-vous viande coupée voilà je
crois que ce coup là je les ai eu à
aucun moment ils peuvent se douter de
mon identité secrète âge mais tu alors
dire un jour jamais shula soir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]